c'est le dossier du jour et c'est un
énorme dossier ça fait mais un boom
si la une de la presse dans le monde
entier megan et harry aurait annoncé
qu'ils vont s'éloigner au moins 500 mâts
par an et qui vont fusionner au moins
six mois par an de la couronne
britannique
l annonce a été faite le jour de
l'anniversaire de kate avait lieu la
veille pardon qu'on me dise pas que
c'est un hasard et pour en parler on a
un spécialiste chroniqueur royal
patrick weber qui est avec nous merci
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
6 panique à buckingham moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire est que la reine était au courant
de cette annonce non elle n'était pas au
courant et c'est ça qui passe vraiment
très très mal avec eux elle a passé une
très mauvaise année vous avez qu'elle
avait parlé de cette annus horribilis en
effet tout y est c'était passé vraiment
plein drame
et là franchement elle paye cher depuis
depuis quelques mois alors le prince
andrew bien sûr les ennuis de santé de
son mari
et puis cette mégane elle a tout fait
pour mes gars ne servent que depuis que
megan est arrivée à la cour d'angleterre
elle a déroulé le red carpet un jeu
vraiment le tapis rouge pour lui donner
des petits privilèges que les autres
n'avaient pas eu par exemple l emmener
avec elle mon c'est hyper drôle mais
enfin c'est comme très important dans le
déroulement quotidien de la monarchie
lors des visites des inaugurations et
tout ça avant une vraie complicité donc
y croyez elle croyait à l'hypothèse
mégane est là elle cela a un peu pris
dans opel a répondu nous vraiment parce
que s'il ya eu tout mon avis est ce que
oui ou non
megan et la sorcière dont on parle c'est
à dire qu'elle a fait virer tous les
domestiques qu'elle éloigne les deux
frères que les deux frères je ne parle
plus on sait qu'il ya des deux frères
qui est des nôtres documentaires et les
jours avec et des jours sans
est ce que c'est la méchante dont on
parle tous et guillaume naudi que c'est
faux ou est ce que tout ça c'est monté
par la presse sans qu'ils l'aiment bien
on fait tient à lui même c'est qu'au
début c'était une héroïne extraordinaire
et la superstar et maintenant on en fait
vraiment la vilaine sorcière coupable et
responsable de tout ce qui est certain
c'est qu'il ya une gigantesque erreur de
casting depuis le début alors c'est pas
du tout une grande staff ça bon tout
court enfin on en a fait une star parce
que ça faisait vendre du papier mais bon
voilà elle jouait pour y voit la rive
ouest
oui petit coin c'est pas à chris kelly
quoi on va se calmer un tout petit peu
mais bon voilà dès le début quand même
temps c'était pas mal parce qu'on est
dans un contexte de briques site à leurs
résultats il faut faire un peu les yeux
doux aux deux côtés de l'atlantique
donc ça passait vraiment bien sur le
papier c'était génial c'était
complètement réussi le truc c'est
qu'elle a eu l'impression qu'elle allait
jouer un rôle de plus le rôle de la
duchesse un petit peu coincé le premier
rôle de sa vie elle se retrouve dans
quelque chose n'est pas du tout un bolt
est sa véritable vie en fait qui va
devenir sa vie et l'a honnêtement très
rapidement elle mesure les limites de
et patrick est ce qu'elle est toxique
est ce que c'est vrai que l influence
totalement à rick est fou amoureux
au point que maintenant les deux frères
ne sont plus de 220 dire que comportent
les deux frères ne sont plus à me elle
dirige tout on rappelle que j'allais
attaquer à des frais d'aller à la chasse
aux rappelle qu'elle est elle est contre
le protocole n'a pas montré l'enfant
quand il fallait le montrer enfin fait
exprès elle fait exprès de faire l'un
verse 2 de la monarchie britannique et
de 2,2 et joop s'adresse à elle joue
vraiment pâle quelques documents que
c'est vrai c'est de prendre part depuis
d'observer les choses je suis désolé
j'ai entre les frais y ait jamais eu
l'ombre ou du début d'un problème dont
elle est arrivée
les problèmes ont commencé à la banque
ses influences des éléments dont il a
alors c'est toujours un peu facile
d'aller chercher la femme en disant
ouais c'est de sa faute mais mais mais
c'est vraiment à ce moment là que les
choses ont commencé à déraper
et puis le truc c'est que les règles
elle les a eus on les lui a donné elle
les a pas respectées les caprices sont
là aussi le personnel ne reste jamais
très longtemps
annie mercier n'oublions pas c'est clair
que c'est vrai p2 qu'il ya de rennes 1re
s qu'est-ce que
la première est gelée oublier la
deuxième du coup ils allaient c'est très
important la deuxième est le premier
neuf et ça va me revenir parce que du
coup tout la deuxième que encore plus
importante c est ce que c'est vrai que
la reine a le aurait le droit si elle
quitte plus de six mois la couronne
britannique aura le droit de récupérer
la garde de l'enfant n'en ont pas venir
tout c'est vrai ça c'est dur mais c'est
un peu blanche neige son nom se retrouve
aux premières questions
les anglais n'avaient sans oreillettes
c'est une vrai interview est ce que les
anglais au début l'adorait ses terres
idole aujourd'hui avec tout ce qu'on
annonce en angleterre est ce qu'elle est
populaire ou détesté alors c'est
partager mais c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ces clivé c'est
vraiment tout l'un ou tout l'autre ouais
j'ai eu pas mal de micro trottoir hier
et est en fait c'est héros elle a raison
parce que franchement cette famille doit
être insupportable
ou alors franchement elle était là pour
faire le job je suis désolé moi j'ai
commenté ce mariage je peux vous dire
que c'est qu'un d'un mariage qui a coûté
une fortune dans l'arène a beaucoup dit
qu'elle a tout payé mais il faut quand
même payer la sécurité faut tenir une
chose donc en fait on vivre au monde
entier une histoire ce sont les seules
stars planétaires à la vendée parler de
scie à main change pas qui c'est
je suis tellement mal c'est vraiment ce
sont des stars planétaires tout le monde
les connaît
alors à partir du moment où on a payé on
a fait en a eu le spectacle on a un
petit peu envie d'avoir ce qu'on appelle
un retour sur 20 est largement aussi
partir à l'étranger qui va payer la sécu
passait pas de personnes qui grande
balade est comme ça développée aux états
unis en fin de droits qui vont bosser je
crois qu'ils vont besoin qu'il ya
quelque chose dont on a peu parlé je
vais être boulanger ça depuis depuis
n'ont justement pas bon c'est lui va
devenir barista chez starbucks
probablement non c'est comme un prénom
michel non je pense que fondamentalement
harry moi j'ai vraiment beaucoup écrit
sur lui et sur son enfance et en fait
l'ombre de diana est toujours là et je
pense que le traumatisme est beaucoup
plus fort chez lui que chez les williams
ont fait est que il a vu ce qui s'est
passé avec sa mère c'est que franchement
atroce en venir c'est un prince bien sûr
il ya toujours pire ok mais il a k'un
lui il a vécu quelque chose d'atroce et
là en posant son choix de se marier de
devenir papa il voit que très vite ça
dérape et qu'il a l'impression de
rejouer à mauvais remake de ce que ça
mais ça dérape à ce que parce que ça ça
à sa femme aussi créé tout c'est elle
qui crée tout ça et dernière question
une bonne besoins de leurs avions
souhaité aux chroniqueurs et corogne
dans le débat doit est ce que vous
pensez j'ai discuté je ne citerai pas
leurs noms mais avec une ou deux
personnes qui connaissent très bien
l'histoire notamment
ils me disent que il pense que ça va
être la première fois qu'on va voir une
femme de prince entre guillemets même
s'ils ne sera jamais roy quitté la
monarchie britannique
nadja le pardon est ce que vous pensez
que megan la finir par partir non
violent il y en a déjà eu c'est vrai si
on se plonge dans l'histoire et empire
je dirais edouard 8 et wallis simpson
l'avenir pas de vendre est une leçon
d'histoire
mais ce qui est certain c'est que c'est
rapide c'est que c'est rapide et skie
pas tout à fait juste dans l'histoire
c'est qu'elle le savait alors en fait le
tout la disputaient les médecins et
william lui a dit ok tu l'âme pas de
souci mais va pas trop vite faudrait
bien mis là il a pris le temps 1
franchement un pôle où il a vraiment
pris le temps ils se sont séparés ils se
sont retrouvés et à partir dont ils se
sont retrouvés ils savaient dangereux il
connaissait la règle du jeu
quel avenir pour vous pour eux le
problème c'est que il va vraiment sur ça
et beaucoup d'intérêt parce que il était
censé incarner le renouveau et la
modernité à la cour alors trouver une
femme divorcée qui travaillent métis
faut pas se voiler la face à cette
impasse en fait parce qu'un aujourd'hui
maintenant bas l'angleterre elle elle
regarde ailleurs ne regarde plus
beaucoup le rêve est donc l aveyron un
rôle à jouer là-dedans il ya quelque
chose savaient pas rentrer trop dans les
détails mais quand noël comme on dit
c'est à dire cet ancien empire
britannique
c'est très important aux yeux de la
reine alors la reine elle est respectée
partout le prince charles pas du tout
alors demain si la reine n'est plus là
il va devenir le chef du commonwealth
mais ça va pas se passer aussi bien pour
la reine le fait d'avoir mégane ça
permettait vraiment d'arrondir les
angles au canada en australie et
certains disent aussi qu'effectivement
la reine maintenant elle a un peu aux
fraises et quelqu'un l'a réduit vous
avez vu le communiqué de buckingham hier
l'idée vraiment c'est de calmer
je vais vraiment de dire attention ok
ils se sont un peu énervés mais on va
trouver des solutions
alors maintenant presse people hashtag
presse people notamment isabelle nos
amis de la presse people on parle d'un
deuxième enfant notamment et même
peut-être d'un enfant qui serait faite
par par gpa avait eu envie de sa patrie
de dire des conneries le médaillon les
démences a fait une émission on n'a pas
opposé mois ils reçoivent qu'en tant que
prince il reçoit une dotation de la
reine qui est haute à sion qui est vers
ce qui est le fruit des impôts d eau d d
d anglais parce qu'il va est ce qu'il va
continuer à percevoir sa rue monk ont
connu cette époque c'est vraiment de
tout l'argent bien sûr c'est le nerf de
tous à dire que faut dire qu'il peut
compter bon alors je connais pas m c'est
ma droite je sais faire et par les
importants banques mais qui peut compter
sur une bonne trentaine de millions dans
les livres sterling en tout cas enfin
d'assaillants il possède en plus de sa
mère il paraît que six millions et demi
à peu près de north east et les parents
de gmail dans l'histoire c'est pas la
grand mère c'est pas l'état c'est son
papa donc le prince charles qui a pas de
problèmes de fin de mois finance ses
deux fils il touche en fait environ ce
qui va continuer donnera sûrement dont
tu parles en fait la dotation c'est
environ 5% de la globalité du salaire de
harry va pas l'empêcher de sucre et
c'est très bien
l'aura pas il n'aura plus d'argent
guillaume liquide le site s'il décide de
quitter la famille royale c'est la loi
ils auront plus l'argent du père et
d'oran vient donc s agit de lui
donneront des conférences comme venir
barack obama ait payé 500 mille dollars
pour donner des conférences
il est un peu plus intelligent que le
prince harry est arrivé plus riches vous
avez qu'ils ont déposés aussi leur nom
en tant que marque là maintenant on a
vraiment fait marrer c'est la finale
franchement j'ai une question à vous
poser aussi est ce que vous savez
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que pense qu'on
n'a pas eu tout entendu williams
notamment son frère comme son grand
frère qui va être froid un jour qu'est
ce qu'ils en pensent aujourd'hui est ce
qu'on sait si c'est là il avait créé une
réaction il ya une réaction en fait
inverse parce que
nos amis mégane et harry ont posté
justement un joyeux anniversaire puisque
c'est là ils ont même bousier
anniversaire de quais pour les accords
de cette annonce l'annoncent les réseaux
sociaux ils se sont déchaînés en disant
ben oui c'est dégueulasse il aurait pu
arriver là vraiment harry et megan avait
décidé là vraiment de de faire du mal à
la fin en tout cas les banques et on la
connaît mais la princesse eugénie qui
s'est marié megan a bousillé son mariage
en annonçant juste au moment du mariage
guy saint-onge monde a parlé une liste
est vrai mais ian pearson a parlé du
mariage de cette princesse d'or devant
tout le monde triche un peu mais bon
c'est un vrai mariage royal sera alors
question quand même nom est cette enfant
ce deuxième enfant né ou n'y a pas de
deuxième manche n'y a pas de preuves on
vient d'assister aux premiers burn-out
royal et bien sûr que oui et on aurait
du sens on s'en doutait quand ils ont
dit dans leur documentaire aux états en
afrique en disant c'est très difficile
je n'imaginais pas ça qui a ri on
découvre qu harry est un garçon fragile
son frère l'a toujours protégé il a fait
beaucoup de dépression est un peu
bipolaires il est fragile le costume est
trop large pour elle est en fait ils ont
dit stop on arrête et on part six mois
par an la vraie question parce que tout
est très flou et personne ne sait
vraiment exactement ce qui va se passer
la vraie question c'est qui va payer
quand ils vont venir leur sécurité ces
six cent mille livres
c'est à dire après sept cent mille euros
par an pour les protéger
rien pour eux comment ben c'est pas
beaucoup d'argent mais donc qui va payer
et surtout comment comment est-ce qu'ils
vont vivre aux états unis c'est à dire
que enfin au canada en plus pour
l'instant ils sont quand même protégé
par le statut de leur grand mère qui est
chef d'état
jamais les paparazzis peuvent pas
rentrer et de buckingham et aller les
photographes ya quand même protégé est
là ils vont devenir des people comme les
autres c'est à dire que ça va s annonce
faire c'est une erreur
ils ont fait de manière précise qu'elle
ait eu une erreur on est en fait ils
n'en peuvent manger visant à aller vers
une solution qui existe dans d'autres
matchs en europe qu'aux pays bas par
exemple et aux monarchies scandinaves en
suède c'est en fait payer à la
prestation ils vont devenir freelance
donc s'ils peuvent faire des oubliés
remplir des obligations et être payé
pour chaque obligation mais ne plus
avoir louis mais jusqu'à maintenant
jusqu'à gagnant tout dire c'était là la
beauté de tout ça c'est que c'était
gratuit
il allait les voilà les navettes ordre
des autorités au démarchage ne faisait
pas payer pour les permis est ce que
vous les vrais spécialistes faisaient de
la monarchie vous avez vu le coup
arriver où le jour où ça a été annoncée
même pour vous c'était à c'est pas moi
mais depuis le début j'ai écrit des
articles j'en ai parlé en étant assez
critique et est en fait on on n'a pas
l'occasion d'en parler et et en fait ça
mais parfois tomber sur le râble en
disant m'enfin est en train de casser le
rêve des gens qu'est ce que c'est elle
est extraordinaire c'est vraiment la
candidate que tout le monde attendait
pourquoi tu n'aimes pas tu préfères qui
est en fait qu télé chiante
je dis très clairement elle est très
belle elle est pas hyper drôle alors
aujourd'hui dans le casting la famille
royale savez la famille royale est bon
j'adore ça mais ça risque quand même un
casting bien casting un peu style
semaine dernière david disent en
attendre sa femme et quatre hippodromes
mathieu moi j'entends ce que vous dites
on sent bon l'autre elle est moins drôle
tout ça mais vous n'avez pas
l'impression qu'on essai transformé la
famille royale en famille ewing et moi
j'ai l'impression de regarder dallas
quand j'étais petit à savoir il ya quand
même un épisode mythique je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez quand bobby et sa
femme pamela qui dansent fork et
reviennent qu'on va tirer surgir c'est
comme le grand climax de cesser on a
l'impression que c'est un peu ça et que
un jour ils vont tous se réconcilier
malheureusement quand peut-être la reine
ne sera plus là on a l'impression que
c'est ce qui va partir plus tard kakà ou
est ce qu'on dit aussi beaucoup apporté
mais c'était effectivement une écrite de
seconde zone et qu'elle rêvait du
premier rôle de sa vie le premier rôle
de sa vie ça a été des traînes et
maintenant elle veut absolument
continuer vers la lumière sur elle et
pour la lumière sur elle il faut qu'elle
passe une sortie qui fasse le buzz
tout était écrit dans sa tête son rêve
et son unique rêve c'était d'être connu
et célèbre elle en train de le faire
pardon voilà et de j'étais là d'aider
les premiers à dénoncer cette firme
c'était me respectes le sang mais non
mais en fait vous vous en remercie et
pas de harry c'est à dire que c'est la
c2a confiance
sous influence d'une fille toxiques et
plus âgés patrick est d'accord avec moi
à son âge qu'à une chose troublante et
j'en ai dit que je vais d'accord c'est
un peu de chances d'être la tripartie
conviendrait à la je ne renonce à leur
rôle au sein des ménages est ce que vous
comprenez 75%
bon écoute et les voilà les gens pour
qui les gens maintenant les gens qu'on
met en angleterre la réponse serait très
bien sûr vous savez pourquoi manger tout
ça me fait bizarre c'est que quand
effectivement on est né pour être le
prince ou ou rennes
on n'a pas le choix à vivre tout ça elle
est arrivée à 40 ans elle savait où il
mettait les pieds elle l'a choisi parce
affleurer dernier passez-vous de crohn
et vous verrez à quel point j'ai juste
mal les deux mois de la fin parce qu'il
faut qu'on y aille rachel et mathieu
pour l'image s'est tu sautes c'est le
musée grévin à londres ont enlevé harry
et mégane la famille royale et les ont
placés ailleurs effectivement et sa
saveur qui est très très fort quand même
bruit mathieu conseillers de revoir the
crown justement est-ce que hariri
la série the crow de son explique c'est
ce que justement harry n'est pas un peu
la réincarnation de sa grande-tante
margaret